[Musik]
afghanistan gehört nach wie vor zu den
frauenfeindlichen und gefährlichsten
ländern der welt
was hat meinen heutigen gast nicht davon
abgehalten mit gerade mal 23 jahren in
herat ihre eigene software firma zu
gründen sieht auch so erfolgreich dass
sie zwei jahre später vom time magazin
zu den 100 einflussreichsten personen
der welt gezählt wurde
heute ist sie bei uns ich freue mich
sehr herzlich willkommen rheuma bub sie
waren gerade mal 15 jahre ja dass sie
das erste mal vor einem computer saßen
und sich einloggen ins internet wie
kommen sie eigentlich an diesen rechner
raum
ich wusste aus büchern von computern als
ich 16 war hörte ich das innere rad ein
internet café eröffnet hatte wir
erkunden aber nur meine brüder und
cousins hin für mädchen war es nicht
angezeigt in einen solchen club zu gehen
man erzählte mir dass es dort eine
magische kiste gab über die man sich mit
der welt verbinden und mit anderen
menschen sprechen konnte und dass man
damit zugang zu allen möglichen
informationen hatte ich wollte diese
zauberkiste unbedingt sehen und bestand
darauf ins internetcafé zu gehen
es dauerte bis ich meine brüder
überreden konnte mich schließlich doch
mitzunehmen
als ich zum ersten mal im internet war
merkte ich dass es eine welt gab von der
ich nichts wusste
wir lebten zu der zeit in finsternis
ohne zugang zu informationen büchern
oder irgendwelche nachrichten
wir wussten nicht was in der welt
geschehe alles was wir kannten war das
fernsehen dass wir sehen durften ja es
gab eine heirat nur eine bibliothek mit
sehr alten büchern aber keinerlei
informationen über das hier und jetzt
es gab fernsehen in afghanistan zu der
zeit
mit sendungen wie meine brüder und mein
vater sehen wollten darüber hinaus
hatten wir keinen zugang zu nachrichten
deshalb war diese kiste für mich auch so
magisch mir war sofort klar dass ich
mein berufsleben um diese technologie
drehen würde nur zehn jahre später
wurden sie vom time magazin ich hab
schon erwähnt unter die 100
einflussreichsten persönlichkeiten
gewählt da hat man natürlich das gefühl
diese begegnung mit dem computer das war
eine wirklich nachhaltige begegnung
ich denke schon
mit dem computer hat sich mein
privatleben aber auch meine berufs
vorstellung völlig verändert ich
beschloss an der uni informatik zu
studieren und habe dort auch
abgeschlossen
das hat mich als person stärker gemacht
und mir selbstvertrauen gegeben
deshalb wollte ich der gesellschaft
etwas zurückgeben und andere mädchen
ausbilden
so wurde ich zur tech unternehmerin und
vom thema gesehen als eine der 100
einflussreichsten personen geehrt
afghanistan gilt immer noch als eines
der frauenfeindlichen länder der welt
zweiter platz gemäss gewissen reporten
gleichzeitig ihre familie hat sie immer
unterstützt oder was verstehe ich
richtig
meine familie hat mich sehr unterstützt
in traditionellen ländern wie
afghanistan spielt die familie eine
immens wichtige rolle bei den
entscheidungen einer frau und gott sei
dank hatte ich einen vater der an mich
glaubte und mich unterstützte
hinsichtlich der schule uni und meiner
beruflichen laufbahn
ich bin gott sehr dankbar für meine
familie
und auch heute sind sie zb ihrer
schwester und einem ihrer brüder sie
haben sechs geschwister sind sie eng
verbunden das neueste projekt das sie
eben erst angefangen haben ist gemeinsam
mit einer ihrer schwestern und zwar
haben sie sich da was ganz spezielles
ausgedacht sie importieren nämlich
kaffee aus zentralamerika und wollen ihn
vermischen mit safran den sie in
afghanistan an pflanzen lassen
erzählen sie ein bisschen mehr davon
wir starteten dieses projekt vor fast
zwei jahren
im letzten jahr haben wir aber vor allem
an der kaffeemischung gearbeitet
die idee dahinter war mit dem safran den
frauen und bauern in afghanistan zu
helfen
ursprünglich wollten wir den safran in
die usa bringen fanden aber nicht
genügend kunden so beschlossen wir den
safran zu mischen er ist mit t das kam
aber in den usa nicht an
also dachten wir ihn mit kaffee zu
mischen arbeiteten wir eine zeit lang am
café mittlerweile haben wir eine gute
qualität erreicht das produkt vertreiben
wir unter der marke breit citizen mit
dem ziel die frauen zu unterstützen
50 prozent des gewinns fließen zurück in
eine stiftung die frauen unterstützt und
ausbildet den safran kaufen wir von
bäuerinnen
wir hoffen dass safran einmal opium
ersetzen kann
was meinen sie damit genau dass man das
ersetzen zwar nicht irgendwann einen
kaffee mit opium dreht und so etwas
sondern sie wollen die opium formen
durch server farmen ersetzen wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe
weil sie auch sagen eigentlich auf dem
weltmarkt haben die beiden produkte
einen ähnlichen preis beides extreme
luxusprodukte kostbare produkte genau
wie sie wissen ist afghanistan eines der
länder die weltweit am meisten opium
produzieren die regierung und
geberländer haben lange versucht die
bauern davon zu überzeugen opium durch
etwas zu ersetzen das ähnlich
einträglich ist zb durch safran die
safran qualität der ist glücklicherweise
sehr hoch speziell im westen in der
gegend von heirat die heißen bauern sind
darauf eingegangen weiter voran so teuer
ist wie opium
die regierung versucht nun den safran
anbau auf ganz afghanistan auszudehnen
und die bauern davon zu überzeugen den
opiumanbau durch safran felder zu
ersetzen und wann werde ich diesen
kaffee trinken können
ich kann ihnen schon bald ein paar
muster schicken
ich bin sehr gespannt ich stelle mir das
speziell wo diese mischung aus den
beiden geschmäckern von kaffee und auf
ran.de mir noch einmal ein bisschen
zurück in ihre geschichte sie haben
gesagt dass ihre familie sehr wichtig
gewesen ist für sie
sie haben ja auch nicht immer in
afghanistan gelebt ihre familie ist
geflohen als sie ein kleines kind waren
während des sowjetisch afghanischen
krieges und zwar via pakistan in den
iran und da haben sie auch die meiste
zeit ihrer kindheit verbracht blicken
die ihr gemeinsam ganz kurz zurück in
der geschichte afghanistans die
leidvolle neuere geschichte des landes
beginnt 1973 mit einem militärputsch
general david wird fünf jahre später
selber in einem politischen coup
gestürzt 1979 marschieren sowjetische
truppen ein
um die kommunisten in afghanistan an der
macht zu halten im islamisch geprägten
staat lehnen viele die kommunistische
herrschaft ab die medien nehmen den
bewaffneten kampf auf und werden von den
usa und weiteren ländern unterstützt die
sowjets 10 1998 ab doch der bürgerkrieg
geht weiter
1996 nehmen die taliban kabul ein und
unterwerfen zwei drittel des landes
ihrer brutalen version des islam 2001
als antwort auf nine eleven bombardieren
die usa afghanistan das land in dem sich
erzfeind osama bin laden versteckt hält
zusammen mit ihren nato-verbündeten
marschieren die amerikanischen
streitkräfte schließlich in kabul ein
doch weder der nato noch den usa oder
den afghanischen sicherheitskräften
gelang es seither die situation im land
zu stabilisieren
mehr als zweieinhalb millionen
flüchtlinge treiben diese kriege über
die grenzen im land selber leben
nochmals fast eineinhalb millionen
menschen als vertriebene geflüchtet vor
den kampfhandlungen 2016 war gar ein
trauriges rekordjahr
über 11.000 zivilisten werden getötet
die meisten durch die taliban
sicherheitschecks heute in kabul
die hauptstadt ist der gefährlichste ort
im land doch auch in den zerklüfteten
bergen und tälern lauert weiter die
gefahr
viele gebiete die bereits gesäubert
waren werden wieder neu vermied durch
die taliban
sie sind 2003 zurückgekehrt nach
afghanistan als teenager damals was war
das für ein land in das sie
zurückgekehrt sind als wir 2003 ins land
zurück gingen war die taliban kultur
immer noch präsent bei den menschen
es bestand aber auch hoffnung weil wir
zur schule und an die uni gehen konnten
vor allem die mädchen meiner generation
die jahre lang zu hause bleiben mussten
waren überglücklich
die mögliche rückkehr in die schulen gab
ihnen den glauben an eine bessere
zukunft
[Musik]
2003 war die infrastruktur schlecht
ausgebaut
auch weigerten sich die meisten familie
damals noch die mädchen zur schule zu
schicken seitdem hat sich aber viel
verändert man sieht viel fortschritt im
vergleich zu 2003 2004 hatte der
damalige us-präsident george bush den
sieg gegen die taliban erklärt trotzdem
ist es ja nach wie vor so dass zwei
drittel des landes von den taliban
beherrscht werden von pakistan her
drängt der es in das land es gibt
unglaublich viele geopolitische
strategische überlegungen wer das land
jetzt wirklich beherrschen soll die
wahlen werden immer wieder verschoben
die sicherheitslage ist schwierig haben
sie die hoffnung dass afghanistan sich
in den nächsten jahren noch einmal
öffnen wir tun wirklich verändern wird
in die richtung in die die jungen
menschen das gerne öffnen würden
natürlich sind wir voller hoffnung
afghanistans bevölkerung ist ja sehr
jung
die hälfte der bevölkerung ist unter 18
es gibt hoffnung für die zukunft trotz
der politischen schwierigkeiten mit den
nachbarstaaten die sich in unsere
politik einmischen und unsere stabilität
untergraben einsehen müssen dass
instabilität in afghanistan sich auch
auf ihre länder und ihre menschen
auswirken wird und dass es besser ist
mit unserem land und unseren politikern
im sinne der stabilität
zusammenzuarbeiten
aber es geschieht auch viel gutes
worüber die medien nicht berichten
es gibt in afghanistan immer noch krieg
und ein sicherheitsproblem in der
hauptstadt aber verglichen mit 2002 oder
2003 ist vieles besser geworden
heute sind 37 prozent der schüler und
mehr als 30 prozent der studenten
weiblich
viele frauen machen politik sind in der
regierung und in führungspositionen
viele frauen haben ihre eigenen firmen
gegründet
es wurden viele strassen und schulhäuser
geburt in den medien berichten und im
westlichen denkens sind diese
fortschritte nicht vorhanden
sie zeigen nicht das wahre leben dort ja
ich bin einverstanden dass bestimmte
sicherheitsprobleme bestehen und dass
die taliban in einigen südlichen
provinzen weiterhin ein problem
darstellen
aber mit der zeit wird sich das alles
verändern
die neue generation will diese
vergangenheit nicht mehr
es gibt ein bericht der reuters
foundation die behauptet dass
afghanistan das zweit gefährlichste land
für frauen nicht nur auf der straße
sondern eben auch zu hause weil zb
häusliche gewalt nicht strafbar ist
an erster stelle steht indien wenn sie
sagen das ist komplett übertrieben und
auch eine verzerrung der tatsachen
leider hat das parlament das gesetz
gegen häusliche gewalt nicht
verabschiedet wegen ein paar dingen die
man ausklammern wollte in ihrer
ablehnung waren die männer nicht allein
sie wurden auch von frauen unterstützt
gewalt gegen frauen können wir nicht
ignorieren oder in abrede stellen es
gibt sie ist glücklicherweise aber wird
heute in den social media über solche
geschichten berichtet das setzt die
regierung und die gerichte unter druck
aktiv zu werden
dank der medien werden viele fälle
gelöst
auch die internationale gemeinde dringt
die regierung maßnahmen zu ergreifen die
haltung zur gewalt gegen frauen hat sich
verändert
das thema wird heute in den berichten
erwähnt früher gab es viel gewalt und
niemand sprach darüber dass heute
darüber gesprochen wird
unterstützt die regierung die menschen
und die
jetzt gebe das thema ernst zu nehmen ich
glaube hier sind wir genau einem punkt
wo sie noch einmal ganz deutlich machen
die sozialen medien können extrem viel
zum guten wenden es kann zu einem
freiheits raum werden das internet und
da fällt mir ein beispiel ein wir haben
einen kurzen einspieler vorbereitet der
rapperin sunita die hätte
zwangsverheiratet werden sollen und sich
auf ihre weise gewehrt hat sie zeigen
auch im anschluss an unser gespräch ein
filmporträt über sunita aber würden die
ganz kurz zu
[Musik]
das video macht sie auf einen schlag
weltberühmt
es war eine schwierige entscheidung das
video auf youtube zu stellen
ich fürchtete nicht vor den reaktionen
in afghanistan und speziell jeder meiner
familie aber ich sagte mir ich muss es
tun selbst wenn ich mir damit schade
glücklicherweise hatte ich sofort viele
fans als meine mutter mich anrief sagte
sie finde den song gut
sie war zwar nicht wirklich glücklich
darüber aber dennoch für mich war das
der größte tag in meinem leben
sie kennen sunita persönlich ja ich
kenne sie um diese geschichte die zeigt
er genau das was sie vorhin gesagt haben
die sozialen medien verändern vieles
wird ein neues afghanistan bild
verbreitet und das wiederum wird auch
druck ausüben auf gewisse einstellungen
von denen sie denken die sind nicht mehr
zeitgemäß einstellungen die vor allem
auch für frauen eine gefährdung bedeuten
[Musik]
vieles hat sich durch die social media
verändert nicht nur für die frauen
sondern auch in der politik die
regierungsarbeit ist transparenter
geworden
das zeigt sich in fällen von korruption
oder häuslicher gewalt die menschen
reagieren positiv auf berichte in den
social media
sie äußern sich klar gegen gewalt an
frauen das war vor einigen jahren noch
nicht so
heute aber sehe ich dass gerade auch die
männer in ihren kommentaren gegen die
gewalt stellung nehmen da ist etwas
gutes ins laufen gekommen
dank dem rap song haben viele von sony
gehört und verständnis entwickelt durch
bildung und mit der zeit lassen sich
viele dieser probleme überwinden
leider kann man dinge nicht durch
zauberei beschleunigen
in den großen städten hat sich bereits
vieles verändert aber in den kleineren
städten in den ländlichen provinzen gibt
es immer noch viel gewalt um diese
kombination bildung und digitalisierung
das ist eigentlich ihr großes thema wenn
wir noch einmal auf ihr auf ihre
biografie zu sprechen kommen die haben
2010 dann ihr eigenes unternehmen
gegründet
man muss sich das mal vorstellen sie
waren so jung haben informatik studiert
in heraus und da gehen sie hin und haben
die afghanen city der software company
gegründet mit ihrer schwester und ich
glaube auch noch mit studien kolleginnen
eine software-firma und haben unter
anderem sehr schnell verschiedene
unternehmen beraten regierungen beraten
angels beraten
wie muss man sich diesen alltag
vorstellen damals noch war es eben nicht
so klar dass eine frau zum beispiel sich
mit einem man gemeinsam an einen tisch
setzen kann
denn ich ihr bruder ist und nicht ihr
ehemann der software gründeten waren wir
unter den ersten weiblichen sie aus in
der tech welt
es wurde nicht von allen in dieser
männlich dominierten branche geschätzt
dass da plötzlich eine frauen firma
kommt und verträge abschließt zu der
zeit gab es ziemlich viele probleme die
zum teil immer noch bestehen
es war nicht einfach frauen anzustellen
und mit us firmen zusammenzuarbeiten
oder mit der regierung verträge
abzuschließen
diese herausforderung zu überwinden hat
mir aber viel gebracht in meiner rolle
als ceo eines tech unternehmens und
hinsichtlich der digitalisierung
es gab eine zeit wo es gefährlich war
aufträge anzunehmen und sich draußen zu
bewegen
auch die angestellten konnten sich nicht
gefahrlos als angestellte unsere firma
zeigen
ich musste wege finden zu meinen kunden
zu gelangen ohne mein leben oder meine
firma in gefahr zu bringen
hier zeigte sich wiederum die schönheit
der social media
ich habe mich bei linkedin angemeldet
und meine kunden zu finden
dort hat mich später auch francesco
lehmann erster investor gefunden
ein italo amerikaner der in new york
lebt er fand mich auf linkedin und bot
mir an für seine firma zu arbeiten
so kamen wir zu einem vertrag und später
investierte er in unsere idee einer
online-plattform die frauen eine stimme
geben sollte auf der sie in blogs ihre
geschichten erzählen und gegen bezahlung
auch content zur verfügung stellen
konnten
so hat sich alles für mich verändert
trotzdem haben sie auch morgen erhalten
irgendwann ging es für sie auch nicht
mehr und sie sind auch new york gezogen
jetzt zu der zeit steckten wir unsere
gewinne in den bau eines centers hier
wollten wir frauen am computer ausbilden
ihnen zeigen wie technologie ihr leben
verändern kann
vor allem dadurch dass sie selbst
vertrauen erlangen
eine digitale stimme bekommen die es
ihnen erlaubt über dinge zu sprechen die
sonst verschwiegen werden
wir haben eine umgebung geschaffen in
der sie ohne ihre identität preiszugeben
über die dinge sprechen können die sie
sonst geheimhalten müssen und das hat
mir einige probleme bereitet darf ich
ganz kurz unterbrechen hat mich das
interessiert sie haben gesagt eine
digitale stimme erhalten
meinen sie damit auch dass das netz ein
raum ist der vor allem einfach sehr viel
mehr publikum arts oder geht es auch
darum dass man anonym sprechen kann im
netz wir haben ein breites publikum aber
auch viele nutzerinnen die hier über die
dinge sprechen können die sie lange für
sich behalten mussten in solch
traditionellen gesellschaften können
frauen oft nicht einmal mit den engsten
freundinnen über persönliche gefühle
sprechen
aus angst dass ihre familie davon
erfährt und es zu konflikten kommt wir
haben den frauen eine plattform gegeben
wo sie sich aussprechen konnten
plötzlich durften sie über ihre wünsche
und träume schreiben die plattform stand
allen offen und ihre beiträge wurden
auch kommentiert niemand verriet ihre
geheimnisse oder zwang sie zu schweigen
[Musik]
es war eine plattform auf der sie offen
über alles sprechen konnten
man sah schnell wie sie dadurch
selbstvertrauen schöpfen
das ist wahnsinnig interessant was sie
erzählen und zwar interessiert mich das
deswegen so sehr weil ich denke wir
sprechen in dem land in dem ich lebe vor
allem darüber dass das internet ein ort
ist in dem wir überwacht werden dass wir
gerade nicht offen sprechen sollen weil
wir nie wissen wer dann die daten alle
sieht um sie erzählen jetzt quasi die
familie die privatsphäre ist der ort wo
überwachung gibt wo man nicht weiß
welche in form
zion wohin geht währenddessen das
internet der raum der freiheit ist
ich meine nicht nur die familien oft ist
es auch die gesellschaft die dir nicht
zu hören will und die sehr schlecht auf
bestimmte dinge reagiert die du sagst so
verhilft die digitalisierung den frauen
zumindest zu einer digitalen stimme mit
der sie über alles sprechen können
wir wollten eine plattform auf der sich
frauen frei und sicher über alles äußern
konnten aber um zurück auf ihren punkt
zu kommen
ja die hälfte der bevölkerung hat immer
noch keinen zugang zum netz das
versuchen wir zu ändern
im westen gibt es zwar netzzugang aber
tatsächlich auf probleme mit dem schutz
der privatsphäre oder der demokratie man
muss sich dieser probleme annehmen und
ich tue das im rahmen der gruppe sind
nun ein zusammenschluss zukünftiger
führungspersönlichkeiten die zusammen
mit tim berners-lee und seiner web
foundation daran arbeiten das netz so
auszugestalten dass man sich darum
sicher bewegen kann
im westen bestehen herausforderungen bei
der digitalisierung in den
traditionellen ländern aber fehlt es am
zugang zum netz die digitalisierung gibt
insbesondere den frauen die möglichkeit
eine mauer zu überwinden
die sie immer gekannt hatten es ist so
interessant
sozusagen der erfinder des internet oder
der vater des internets wie viele sagen
da auch schon zu gast bei uns und ich
kann mich sehr gut erinnern wie sehr er
gesagt hat das internet ist der raum der
freiheit und ein die abbas verraten wann
ist etwas grundsätzlich schief gegangen
mit unserer idee die wir einmal herzen
und sie stehen eigentlich hier als eine
neue generation für mich von frauen die
sagen ja aber genau das kann das
internet immer noch sein ein raum der
freiheit
aber mit der freiheit kommt auch
verantwortung für länder wie unseres ist
das internet ein grundwerkzeug und die
regierung steht in der verantwortung die
infrastruktur zu errichten damit alle
netzzugang haben und es nutzen können
die firmen wiederum haben die
verantwortung den zugang für alle
erschwinglich zu machen und die
datensicherheit zu garantieren
sie erwähnten ja dass sie vorsichtig
damit sind was sie im internet
verbreiten
regierungen und firmen stehen hier in
der pflicht auch die nutzer haben eine
verantwortung in bezug auf den inhalt
den sie kreieren damit sich frauen und
kinder im internet wohl fühlen können an
diesen herausforderungen arbeitet die
stiftung und zusammen mit tim
berners-lee versuchen wir ein
bewusstsein dafür zu schaffen dass
datensicherheit wichtig ist wir müssen
ein besseres netz für die künftige
generation bauen einen geschützten
sicheren offenen ort den alle nutzen
können
andererseits aber glaube ich dass es
insbesondere für frauen in
traditionellen ländern ein großartiges
werkzeug ist die keinen zugang zu
informationen zu gar nichts haben das
internet die technologie und die
digitalisierung geben ihnen hoffnung für
die zukunft fähigkeiten zugang zu
besserer bildung oder bildung überhaupt
und erlauben ihnen vor allem finanzielle
unabhängigkeit
das ist entscheidend dafür dass die
männer in traditionellen ländern ihre
haltung frauen und ihren fähigkeiten
gegenüber ändern
sie haben auch mit francesco ideen sie
vorhin erwähnt haben diesen digitale
diesen fonds gegründet und da geht es
genau darum solche räume zu etablieren
also ganze technologie zentren für
mädchen und junge frauen wo eben
computer stehen wo sie kurse belegen
können im programmieren in bloggen aber
auch zb den finanzierungsmöglichkeiten
zu finden weil sie gesagt haben es gibt
natürlich die schwierigkeit dass frauen
oft nicht einmal ein eigenes konto haben
es ist sehr einfach für die männer die
verdienste der frauen die sie zu hause
mit ihrem computer sozusagen verdienen
einfach abzuzweigen
und sie lernen den frauen auch zum
beispiel mit bitcoin umzugehen als mit
virtuellen währungen mit dem digital
citizen fand wollen wir zeigen dass
technologie eine option für alle sein
soll
insbesondere für frauen in
traditionellen ländern
ich glaube an das recht auf
chancengleichheit und den zugang zur
ausbildung für alle mit dem digital
citizen fand schaffen wir ein angebot
für frauen in afghanistan und gehen
kurse über das programmieren social
media betriebswirtschaft und
finanzwissen und eben auch bitcoin 2013
starteten wir die plattform women's
annex auf der frauen ihre blogs anboten
dafür mussten wir sie bezahlen eine
schwierigkeit war dass viele von ihnen
kein
konto hatten oft konfiszierte die
familie auch das geld das wir ihnen
bezahlten die frauen konnten nicht frei
über ihr geld verfügen
natürlich haben frauen immer auch den
wunsch ihre familie zu unterstützen
aber wenn sie etwas für sich zurücklegen
wollten konnten sie das nicht weil ihnen
ihr geld weggenommen wurde
wir wollten sicherstellen dass die
frauen über ihr eigenes geld bestimmen
konnten
als er von bitkom hörten wollten wir es
nach afghanistan bringen und unseren
nutzerinnen in dieser währung bezahlen
es war sicher schnell und damit konnten
die frauen über ihr geld entscheiden es
ihren familien aus freien stücken geben
oder für sich zurück liegen
so begann das mit bitcoin und blog sie
haben unglaublich viel energie ziehen
ganz viele projekte hoch wir haben schon
von safran und kaffee gehört jetzt geht
es um die digitalen schulzimmer bitcoin
umso weiter
sie haben auch ein roboter team ein
mädchenteam dass ich mit robotik
auseinandergesetzt hat ins leben gerufen
und unterstützt die bilder dieser
mädchen gingen um die welt die mädchen
waren auch in einem wettbewerb in den
usa haben zuerst schwierigkeiten
einzureisen aufgrund von visa problemen
zuletzt hat sich sogar ivanka trump
stark gemacht für diese wies auf die
mädchen und sie haben tatsächlich auch
eine medaille gewonnen
allerdings ist zehn tage später der
vater des einen mädchens beim suizid
attentat ums leben gekommen
gibt es momente wo sie denkt diese
ganzen erfolgsgeschichten zeigen doch
irgendwie auch dann nur halb wie
schwierig es ist die realität wirklich
zu verändern
angesichts dessen was wir erreicht haben
versuche ich auch in den schwierigkeiten
das positive zu sehen
also positiv wir arbeiten in einem vom
krieg zerrissenen land wo 40 prozent der
bevölkerung in armut leben und frauen
immer noch als bürger zweiter klasse
gelten
deshalb glaube ich dass diese
erfolgsgeschichte in der gesellschaft
das vertrauen in frauen und ihre
fähigkeiten stärkt und sie durch ihre
familien unterstützt werden um lücken ja
darf ihn das mädchen robotics team
wollte vor zwei jahren an einem
wettbewerb teilnehmen und fand seinen
visa antrag abgelehnt
als ich zeigte dass nur teams aus zwei
ländern vor diesem problem standen haben
wir das wiederum nicht schweigend
hingenommen sondern über die social
media bekannt gemacht die medien griffen
die geschichte denn auch auf und als die
öffentlichkeit davon erfuhr
unterzeichneten 53 abgeordnete eine
petition und schließlich setzte sich
auch präsident trump für die mädchen ein
die dann ihr visa erhielten
wichtig ist aber nicht wie die mädchen
in die usa kamen sondern was danach
geschah sie wurden nach ihrer rückkehr
zu einer vision der hoffnung in einem
land das über jahrhunderte die
fähigkeiten von frauen in wissenschaft
und anderen bereichen ignorierte dieses
team brachte uns die einsicht dass wir
den wandel in der technologie selbst
schaffen müssen und dass es auch für
mädchen wichtig ist robotics und
mathematik kenntnisse zu erwerben
wegen ihnen haben sehr viele afghanen
ihre haltung zu den fähigkeiten von
frauen verändert heute haben wir die
unterstützung von regierung parlament
und dem privatsektor für diese
initiative die wir jetzt ausweiten
können
dieses beispiel zeigt wie viel sich mit
solchen initiativen verändern lässt
ich habe ein sehr vielen projekten
mitgearbeitet hier aber konnte man die
auswirkung auf die gesell
direkt sehen das war vielleicht mein
erfolgreichstes projekt das robotics
team hat viel bewirkt
sie wurden zu einem symbol für mut für
abertausende von kindern nicht nur in
afghanistan sondern überall in der welt
dafür dass jeder und jeder es schaffen
kann mit der nötigen unterstützung und
wenn sich eine chance bietet
es sind vielleicht diese vorbilder die
mehr verändern die geschichten die mehr
verändern die beispielsweise die gesetze
denn das afghanische gesetz sieht ja
eine schulpflicht vor auch für mädchen
und dennoch gibt es ganz viele mädchen
die die schule nicht besuchen weil die
familien das nicht wollen
leider ist das so
aber auch da hat sich dank diesem team
viel verändert einige familien haben
gesehen dass mädchen auch ingenieur
werden können und welche vorteile das
hat nach der rückkehr des teams haben
sich 544 studentinnen für die robotics
kurse eingeschrieben
es hat sich wirklich viel verändert
das robotics team ist heute zu einem
symbol für hoffnung und einheit in ganz
afghanistan geworden
mindestens 90 prozent der kommentare die
man liest sind positiv so etwas gab es
in der vergangenheit nicht über
unternehmens führerinnen oder frauen in
der regierung oder den medien gab es
immer sehr viele negative kommentare
seitens der männer nicht aber über
dieses robotics team
manchmal gibt es so ein licht im dunkel
und genau das geschah hier
[Musik]
wegen dieses team ist richten wir jetzt
auch die erste sein stack schule ein mit
fokus auf künstlicher intelligenz und
robotik
das haben die regierung der afghanische
präsident und das parlament akzeptiert
und so planen wir fünf solcher schulen
in fünf regionen von afghanistan
in den nächsten drei jahren planen wie
eine high tech universität nach dem
modell des m
damit soll afghanistan in den nächsten
drei jahren von einem kriegsland zu
einem high tech land werden
und all das begann mit diesen sechs
afghanischen mädchens für mich ist es
nicht ganz einfach zu verstehen die
einerseits ihre bildungsprojekte die
sehr eindrücklich sind die sie aufbauen
unterstützt werden sogar von der
afghanischen regierung und andererseits
ist diese verschiedenen gruppen gibt
auch die taliban gibt die immer noch
diese sehr rückständige frauenbild haben
sage ich einmal und sie haben vorhin
auch gesagt frauen werden auf zwei
krasse bilder angesehen ist diese
gesellschaft sehr zerrissen
es gibt eine große kluft zwischen den
großen städten und den kleineren städten
und den ländlichen regionen die sich
leider vertieft hat im laufe der zeit in
den großen städten hat sich die lage der
frau stark verändert hier gehen mädchen
zur schule frauen können
unternehmerinnen werden für die medien
im parlament oder in der regierung
arbeiten
in ländlichen gegenden ist immer noch
der geist der taliban der die menschen
einschränkt hier wo frauen als bürger
zweiter klasse gelten soll mädchen jung
heiraten
es braucht zeit und mittel technologie
und eine gute ausbildung werden nicht
nur in den großen städten benötigt die
regierung sollte auch in ländliche
gebiete investieren
vergessen wir nicht dass immer noch die
hälfte der bevölkerung dort liebt und
wenn wir heute nicht investieren kann
sich das in der zukunft rächen und die
finsternis andauern
in unseren gesprächen mit dem
afghanischen präsidenten und anderen
entscheidungsträgern betonen wir dass
sich afghanistan nicht nur auf den krieg
und den kampf gegen die taliban
konzentrieren darf weil wir sonst den
kampf um die zukunft dieser generation
verlieren die hälfte der bevölkerung ist
auf investitionen in die bildung
angewiesen
[Musik]
40 prozent der jungen generation haben
immer noch keine arbeit
natürlich braucht es mittel für das
militär
aber es braucht auch eine strategie
damit die junge generation die
notwendigen fähigkeiten für ihr
berufsleben erwirkt und die wirtschaft
wachsen kann
das geschieht nur wenn wir heute an
diese generation denkt und dazu gehört
eben auch menschen eine arbeit zu geben
und deswegen ist es für sie zum beispiel
wichtig den saft frauen von frauen an
bauen zu lassen all die frauen auch
arbeit brauchen engagieren sie
eigentlich vor allem gerne frauen weil
sie denken vor allem die frauen brauchen
auch jobmöglichkeiten oder sind die
frauen auch zuverlässige partnerin
frauen sind verlässlicher als partner
und sie machen die hälfte der
bevölkerung aus
wenn wir heute nicht in sie investieren
gibt es in diesem land keinen erfolg und
kein wachstum
wir müssen auch in dieser hälfte der
bevölkerung investieren damit sie eine
gute ausbildung hat und finanziell
unabhängig sein kann
dank beruflicher qualifikationen können
frauen einen beitrag zu ihrer familie
der gemeinde und der gesellschaft als
ganzes leisten
ich denke es gibt bereits viele angebote
für männer die sich auch in zukunft von
der gesellschaft unterstützt werden
mir ist es wichtig etwas für meine
generation zu tun
für mich meine mutter meine cousinen
technologie und bildung haben mir
geholfen mein leben zu verändern
jetzt ist das zeit der gesellschaft
etwas zurückzugeben indem ich mit frauen
arbeiten und ihnen
für ihre ziele und träume im leben zu
erreichen ich gebe ihnen lediglich die
werkzeuge
was sie dann damit in ihrem leben machen
liegt an ihnen
sie geben das werkzeug sie schaffen
bildungsmöglichkeiten aber was sie auch
tun ist sie lassen geschichten erzählen
sie haben jetzt schon mehrere male film
next erwähnt auch eine initiative mit
dem sie zusammenarbeiten auf eine
plattform auf der frauen aber auch
männer ihre blogs staaten können ihre
blogs also videoblogs er ihre
geschichten erzählen interviews
hochladen und das erinnert mich so ein
bisschen daran dass es in der
philosophie immer schon die tradition
gab der so genannten narrativen ethik
also die überzeugung dass wir nicht mit
argumenten weiterkommen sondern manchmal
wirklich nur mit den geschichten mit den
vorbildern mit den träumen mit den
visionen die wir aber sehr plastisch
werden lassen um in diesem zusammenhang
interessiert mich was sie eigentlich
denken welche bilder von afghanistan
sich auch in unseren köpfen ändern
müssten weil wir haben ja im westen auch
ein bestimmtes bild von afghanistan und
es gibt diesen vorwurf des
literaturwissenschaftlers edward said
der gesagt hat es gibt diesen
occidentalis muss wir schauen immer aus
einer idee orientalismus entschuldigung
aus einer idee der überlegenheit auf
diese länder empfinden die das so und
glauben sie wir haben wirklich auch die
falschen bilder im kopf von afghanistan
ehrlich gesagt denke ich dass ihr bild
lediglich zehn bis 20 prozent der
realität in afghanistan abdeckt
afghanistan mit seinen 34 millionen
menschen lebt viele menschen sind
glücklich in ihrer ehe gehen und parties
zur schule haben hoffnungen und träume
für die zukunft darüber berichten die
medien nicht es gibt viele
erfolgsgeschichten viele erfolgreiche
unternehmerinnen es geschieht auch viel
gutes in auf
pakistan das brauchen wir um wieder
hoffnung zu haben
auch in afghanistan berichten die medien
nur über das dunkel die finsternis hilft
aber unserem land und unsere generation
nicht die junge generation braucht das
licht der hoffnung
leider haben viele der am besten
ausgebildeten jungen menschen
afghanistan verlassen
sie fehlen beim wiederaufbau des landes
wir brauchen heute investitionen
hoffnung und wir müssen zusammenarbeiten
um für uns alle eine bessere zukunft zu
bauen
es gibt viele kluge junge menschen in
afghanistan mit viel talent und mit
hoffnungen und träumen für die zukunft
was ich als bürgerin tun kann ist so
vielen menschen wie nur möglich
werkzeuge an die hand zu geben
im juni findet übrigens die größte
konferenz zur technologie innovation
kunst und unternehmertum für junge
weibliche talente statt
viele junge frauen erhalten dort die
möglichkeit ihre projekte ins
rampenlicht zu stellen
viele teilnehmerinnen haben start ups in
unterschiedlichen branchen gegründet
junge frauen zum beispiel die gemeinsam
einen rennwagen entwickeln oder
industrieroboter fertigen
genau das brauchen wir darauf müssen wir
unsere aufmerksamkeit richten wir müssen
den sie investieren und ihnen helfen
ihre zukunft zu bauen
krieg und unsicherheit darf uns nicht
davon abhalten an die nächste generation
zu denken und in die talente in
afghanistan zu investieren
es braucht nicht so sehr spenden sondern
investitionen und mittel damit die
menschen ihre eigene zukunft bauen
können so schafft man eine
bürgergesellschaft
dafür braucht es zuallererst wissen dann
investitionen damit unternehmen
gegründet werden können für den aufbau
unserer gesellschaft das braucht es
heute immer wieder die kraft der frauen
sozusagen in diesem zusammenhang
und darüber möchte ich mit ihnen auch
noch sprechen sie waren keynote
speakerin world webforum und die
digitalisierung braucht natürlich frauen
wie sie die sich da reinschmeißen in
diese ganzen neuen bewegungen in diesen
ganzen bereich der innovation was waren
die themen wo sie denken das ist die
zukunft da müssen wir hin und da
brauchen wir vor allem auch noch mehr
innovationen in dem werk webforum sehr
dankbar für die einladung in die schweiz
und die möglichkeit über die
vorstellungskraft und über meine
geschichte und meine arbeit zu sprechen
was waren ihre frage schon wieder was
sind die wirklich wichtigen themen von
denen sie denken die sollten die richtig
jetzt angehen im bereich der
digitalisierung aus ihrer sicht
am wichtigsten ist die frage des zugangs
millionen von frauen sind ausgesperrt
vom netz zuallererst müssen zugang und
anschlussmöglichkeiten geschaffen werden
zweitens gilt es das wissen und die
fähigkeiten zu vermitteln damit sie die
geräte nutzen können um ihr leben und
das leben ihrer gemeinschaft zu
verbessern um im wettbewerb des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts bestehen
zu können brauchen unsere länder zugang
zu den technologien geräten und dem
wissen die unsere welt verändern
leider gibt es nicht nur in afghanistan
sondern auch in vielen anderen ländern
keine chancengleichheit beim zugang zur
bildung
es gibt eine gewaltige kluft zwischen
den reichsten und den ärmsten ländern
während wir immer noch keinen zugang zum
wissen und zum internet haben fürchtet
man sich in der westlichen welt davor
dass in zehn jahren künstliche
intelligenz und roboter alles
kontrollieren
das ist eine gewaltige kluft deshalb
brauchen diese länder den gleichen
zugang
um diese ängste die sie gerade
beschreiben das ist tatsächlich so dass
habe ich vorhin schon erwähnt die sagen
wir mal grundstimmung bezüglich der
digitalisierung ist ein bisschen in sich
zusammengekracht in unseren ländern ich
habe den eindruck man hat vor allem die
ängste im moment über die man diskutiert
eben die angst vor der künstlichen
intelligenz dass uns die arbeit ausgehen
können sie aber auch eben die angst vor
der überwachung finden sie das alles
übertrieben denken sie guck doch mal
welche freiheit da auf uns wartet guckt
mal welche möglichkeiten bestehen
ich denke nicht dass es übertrieben ist
aber man muss auch die chancen darin
sehen
mit der künstlichen intelligenz werden
nicht alle stellen wegfallen
es werden auch neue geschaffen wird das
leben der menschen einfacher machen aber
damit erwächst uns auch eine
verantwortung zb stehlen dem hightech
bereich zu schaffen
ich bin sicher dass sich viele in der
tech branche mit diesen fragen
auseinandersetzen und um gute lösungen
für die menschen bemüht sind
ich befürchte für unsere traditionellen
länder in afrika zum beispiel hat nur
eine von zehn frauen je einen computer
gesehen dass der abstand zum rest der
welt immer mehr anwächst
hier sehe ich eine große herausforderung
und interessant ist ich lebe in einem
land wo die frauen zugang haben zum
internet praktisch alle und die frauen
genauso wie die männer aber die
tech-branche ist immer noch sehr stark
dominiert von den männern nur gerade 14
aller berufe sind von frauen ausgeübt im
bereich high tech branche
und es gibt eine initiative von frauen
aus der tech-branche die heißt wie shake
und die betonen ganz stark wir brauchen
mehr diversity in der tech-branche
weil erstens die teams arbeiten besser
also mehr diversity heißt auch mehr
produktivität
mehr innovation aber es ist auch so dass
die zukunft ja eine digitale sein wird
und wenn die frauen nicht mitziehen dann
wird die ganze welt überzogen werden mit
produkten die aus meiner sicht
entwickelt worden sind
das stimmt und da muss man aktiv werden
in westlichen ländern wie der schweiz
damit die mädchen bereits in jungen
jahren lernen innovativ zu sein und
verstehen wie wichtig technologie auch
für sie ist gerade junge mädchen müssen
ans programmieren und das entwickeln
herangeführt werden
die welt der technologie sollte
attraktiv und spannend für sie gestaltet
werden
mit frauen als vorbilder damit dieser
weg geber erscheint vielleicht fühlen
sich frauen in diesem umfeld auch nicht
wirklich wohl weil sie in einer
verschwindenden minderheit sind
gerade in großen firmen ist die
belegschaft überwiegend männlich aber
wenn wir in unternehmerinnen investieren
mehr weibliche vorbilder in der
tech-welt haben und junge mädchen ans
programmieren und den maschinenbau
heranführen können wir diese lücke
vielleicht schließen
[Musik]
in unseren ländern versuchen wir über
die bildung vorzugehen in traditionellen
ländern ist technologie ein großartiges
werkzeug gerade für frauen die aus
kulturellen gründen zwar zu hause
bleiben aber so trotzdem arbeiten können
überall zu hause auch ein computer
aufstellen kann und sich einloggen ich
leider letzten mich hat lea von wieder
sehr beeindruckt das ist eine junge
japanerin im silicon valley hat das
cover bands erfunden das ist ein hippes
trucker sozusagen ein baum mit dem man
die fruchtbarkeit bestimmen kann und hat
sozusagen auch eine lücke geschlossen
weil interessanterweise hatte zum
beispiel das abo gesundheits band erst
einmal ganz viele daten gemessen aber
ausgerechnet die fruchtbarkeit der frau
die war
das tool da gar nicht installiert wo wir
ja sehen wenn die frauen nicht auch apps
entwickeln dann jetzt keine apps geben
die auf die bedürfnisse von frauen
reagieren und diese lea von wieder die
betont allerdings auch dass es in
süditalien durchaus auch sexismus gibt
und es schwieriger ist für frauen in
diesen branchen sich wirklich zu
etablieren
wie blicken sie aus ihrer vergangenheit
auf den sexismus in unseren ländern
finden sind das alles ein bisschen
wehleidig und lächerlich das was wir auf
sexismus bezeichnen
ich habe einiges gehört über das silicon
valley
es wird also schon stimmen dank der mito
bewegung hat man begonnen darüber zu
sprechen
vielleicht zwingt dass die männer auch
achtsam zu sein
es handelt sich um ein universelles
problem das in allen männerdominierten
branchen existiert wo frauen sich unwohl
fühlen und sie entsprechend
untervertreten sind aber wenn wir das
thema in die öffentlichkeit in die
politik und regierung tragen wird sich
das verändern ich weiß nicht ob ich ihre
frage beantwortet haben
nein ich finde schon dass sie darauf
geantwortet haben sie haben nur keine
einschätzung abgegeben
das interessiert mich wirklich wie sie
als eine frau die afghanistan sehr gut
kennt die überhaupt viele länder gut
kennt aber die auch in new york lebt sie
haben ja bestimmt auch die ganze debatte
mitbekommen wo man ja sagen kann endlich
und da hat sozusagen haben die sozialen
medien den frauen in ihrer stimme die
sich aus unterdrückt empfindet auch die
möglichkeit geben sich zu äußern aber
gleichzeitig könnten sie ja auch sagen
bezüglich unterdrückung von frauen habt
ihr überhaupt gar keine ahnung
unter freundinnen sprechen wir oft über
diese themen gerade meine freundinnen in
den usa erzählen mir dass aggressives
und unangebrachtes verhalten von männern
zu ihrem alltag gehört aber auch hier
helfen die social media und die miete
bewegung dinge zu verändern damit frauen
sich frei und sicher fühlen bei der
arbeit oder wenn sie einen investor
aufsuchen
leider gab es ja fälle wo männer nicht
investierten wenn die frau nicht auf die
ihren forderungen einging
also braucht es mehr frauen die in
frauen investieren
die politiker müssen sich des themas
annehmen
[Musik]
firmenkulturen müssen sich ändern
es braucht mehr frauen in
leitungspositionen frauen sollten andere
frauen unterstützen damit sich das
ändert
und man sollte auch den männern helfen
ihr verhalten zu reflektieren
wenn wir über diversity sprechen dann
sind die immer schnell beim thema mann
frau oder vielleicht auch noch traums
aber die ganze frage der
geschlechtergerechtigkeit aber es gibt
noch andere aspekte der diversity
nämlich zb die frage was brauchen
eigentlich menschen in anderen ländern
in anderen kulturen und ein anderes
schönes beispiel ist die up mp sah das
ist eine ab mit der man ohne ein konto
zu besitzen mit dem smartphone bezahlen
kann die wird in afrika sehr sehr viel
genutzt und was daran schön ist an dem
beispiel ist zu zeigen dass die
entwicklung von ups wenn die wirklich
passt genau auf die bedürfnisse der
menschen geschieht kann den menschen
wirklich ganz neue freiheit räume
eröffnen
ich frage mich einfach und würde gerne
ihre meinung dazu hören
wie groß ist die gefahr dass eigentlich
wieder investoren die schon sehr sehr
viel haben schon sehr reich sind in
diese länder reingehen ups entwickeln
und wiederum das ganze geld absahnen um
nicht von unten heraus wie eine große
bewegung sozusagen die ups entwickelt
werden
investoren die wollen dass die menschen
in anderen ländern ihre apps nutzen
müssen sicherstellen dass diese auf die
bedürfnisse der menschen und der kultur
dort abgestimmt sind
sonst sind sie langfristig nicht
erfolgreich
zu investieren die von leuten entwickelt
wurden die wissen worum es geht und
welche schwierigkeiten bestehen
leider gilt das nicht nur für apps das
zeigt sich auch bei den internationalen
geldgebern die zu wissen glauben was
richtig ist für die menschen vor ort und
entsprechend ihrer einschätzung
entscheiden
das funktioniert oft nicht weil sie
nichts über die kulturellen hinter nisse
wissen oder darüber was genau eine frau
oder ein mann in dieser gesellschaft
braucht deshalb ist bei solchen vorhaben
diversity rauch so wichtig die frauen
mit am tisch sitzen
denn sie wissen was sie brauchen oder
wollen und verstehen was wirklich
wichtig ist für die gemeinschaft es
braucht die weibliche perspektive sie
viel zu kreativen ideen und innovativen
produkten bei uns sehen wir dass frauen
oft vertrauter sind mit den lokalen
gegebenheiten
sie bringen aspekte ein die die männer
nicht gedacht haben weil sie mit
allgemeinen fragen beschäftigt waren
weil die frauen aber unterschiedliche
lösungsansätze finden ist das produkt am
ende viel ausgewogener und besser auf
die bedürfnisse der gemeinschaft
abgestimmt
das läuft überall ähnlich und genau
deshalb braucht es teams die breit
zusammengesetzt sind mit frauen aber
auch vertretern von minderheiten oder
behinderten und ein umfeld wo sie ihre
einsichten mit einbringen können damit
innovativere produkte entstehen
das braucht es heute ist eigentlich der
alte begriff der glokalisierung
globalisierung um lokales denken müssen
zusammenfinden
ich nehme das sehr gerne als schlusswort
ich danke ihnen sehr dass sie bei uns zu
gast waren danke sehr
[Musik]